hi my name is Kurt I'm Josh we were
flostor Damas we're in Austin Texas
first South by Southwest 2012 we're
gonna give you guys a little bit of a
preview of what we're using for our live
set up these days we switch things up to
come down here to South by Southwest and
go through a little rolling suitcase
here and show you what we do we like to
do things on a budget so we like try to
keep things as cheap as possible so I'm
gonna start it out with this $3 at IKEA
it's a little laptop stand that they
sell it's good for like putting
keyboards up and stuff like that so we
put our controllers on this throw here
we're running a new system now it's all
Ableton driven all right with a MacBook
it's like the brain and we both have two
different controllers right now Josh
this is the growl my bath towel yeah
first we get the it's clean it's clean
everybody you guys can't feel it though
it's a little moist so josh is using
this would you like to talk about this
to them the apc40
it's made by a chi and it's just an
awesome MIDI controller man it's funny
because I've never used like MIDI stuff
before or not like for live to our live
show or for performing we're all sweet
used-to-be on sarado and wears a
straight ej so it's kind of amazing to
like have to learn something and also
learn it on the fly in front of a large
crowd of people oh yeah I'm having fun
with it all right
and so that's for Josh that's his side
of things but what we do is we don't
have that here cuz the club usually
provides it but we have a pioneer 800
mixer and we plug are able to set up
into that via this tractor sound card
and this actually goes goes for out so
we can have each individual channel have
like one of the channels will have a
vocal track one might have some drums
from one of the songs we produced and
one of them might be like someone else's
song that we're that we liked so we want
it will blend in our set will blend a
little bit of like our original drum
samples from our songs as well as just
like three mixing songs yeah so that
comes out of this shout it to Native
Instruments and then I'm also a mind the
things I'm using a Novation Launchpad
and so with this I can trigger the clips
and like layers just like Josh can but I
can also drum things out and play little
samples and whatnot and for it to do
effects and all of that I will use my
iPad and on my iPad I have a program
called touchable and I can't really pull
it up right now because it goes over
Wi-Fi but I we set up a network at that
at the club and I can run different
filters effects echoes all of that stuff
to make things even more intense all of
that goes through a MacBook Pro I'm sure
you have one or have seen on last but
not least to monitor what we're doing
what is the brand of these Josh it's the
ìiî headphones and actually this is the
the fool's gold model shout out to
fool's gold records that's our label
yeah and they are pretty much
unbreakable because when you're on the
road a studio headphones are great but
like they're not designed to be beaten
up every single night and like checked
and luggage or thrown like in carry-on
or whatever so those headphones are
literally unbreakable you can bend them
any which way and yeah they're great for
us Total Recall is cool we've been like
sort of working on music for years and
years and years but like Total Recall is
will the first record where we kind of
like him I feel like we hit our stride
as far as how he and I work together and
on the tech side of things we use
Dropbox because he lives in Brooklyn I'm
in Chicago so I'm I'm constantly working
on something in Chicago and then putting
it in the Dropbox and the sends right
over to him and he wakes up in the
morning and it's just right there
and he can see what I did and edit and
kind of work in that session I send it
back and we use logic
as a musical program so yeah so that was
really cool and I feel like the the EP I
don't know just shows that's the that's
the first like piece of work that we've
made with that kind of structure and
it's I do this more streamline our sound
kind of used to be kind of all over the
place but like now it's we have this
kind of like rhythm going down and we
know who does what and like it's just
kind of narrowed it down for us yeah
yeah we use we use Dropbox and chair
tool as two different things for us and
it's awesome because we can collaborate
with each other and collaborate with
artists like living in Amsterdam or
wherever and it's good it's a good tool
for this day and age because everyone's
making music everywhere in the world